now that the documentary is out has any
of like the male directors like reached
out to Louis Mal and Franco zafarelli
they're both dead you know I the
director of the Blue Lagoon is still
alive he did send me up he I saw his
name on my phone and I was like oh oh
what do I do and I let it go to
voicemail because I was like oh I want
to see what the tone is and it he wants
to chat I don't know about what I don't
feel like bringing any of it up back up
again and like it's not about that you
know
um but it's it was
it was about you know these males
needing me to be in a certain category
to serve their story and it never was
about me it never it was not never
protective of me it was fun and loving
at times but it was
I was a I was just there I was upon